Bruce hooli he is the morning host on
105.7 to zone the Fox affiliate in
Columbus the show that precedes this
show and Bruce's has plugged in on Ohio
State football is anybody is in that
market and Bruce joins us now describe
the reaction in Columbus to this news
today Bruce well I think it's disbelief
and there are a lot of people looking
for reasons to exonerate Urban Meyer a
lot of people you know claiming that the
alleged victim in this case is not
telling the truth and a really obscure
somewhat the only thing that matters is
is the one handed Urban Meyer violate
his contract by not reporting what he
had reasonable belief to be abuse by one
of his staff members and then number two
the public perception problem Dan that
comes with the possibility that he
wasn't truthful last week when he
commented on this in Chicago at the Big
Ten kickoff luncheon all right so what
happens now with practice opening up on
Friday you got the coach on paid
administrative leave what happens next
well I think two things happen number
one Ohio State if they have not already
made up their mind to part with Urban
Meyer and they're not just taking a
pause to negotiate a settlement they
have to do an independent investigation
that would involve some firm that
specializes in looking at text messages
emails and everything else to determine
whether Urban Meyer did or didn't know
about this abuse
number two the sharks are circling media
wise you got every entity from around
the country coming in here now filing
Freedom of Information requests they're
looking for the same thing and that's
really what I think of high states
afraid of is the additional reporting
because they were it was death by a
thousand paper cuts during the Jim
Tressel thing where they stood by the
coach on a day-to-day basis never put
him on leave and every day there was a
new headline and inmate Ohio State look
worse virtually every single day how
much do you think Ohio State the
athletic department learned from Jim
Tressel situation that helps them in
this situation with Urban Meyer
well clearly they learn something
because they put herbin on
administrative leave yesterday which was
the right move for them and the right
move for him too shouldn't expect a guy
who has to exonerate himself to be
balancing coaching a team and devoting
himself to proving that he should still
be your football coach they didn't learn
anything from a crisis management
perspective though I can tell you that
because last week when every Meyer went
to Chicago he was had 36 hours notice he
was going to have to react to a Bret
McMurphy report about an incident in
2015 involving a fired assistant coach
Zack Smith and possible domestic
violence and no other media entity could
get its hands on that police report the
Powell Police Department said the report
didn't exist well if Brad McMurphy had
that report he clearly got it from the
victims attorney not going to get it
from the alleged abusers attorney
because it makes the alleged abuser look
bad and yet Obon Meyer with every
reasonable expectation to know that Bret
McMurphy had cultivated like all good
reporters do a relationship with a
source urban went up there and he went
all in on that incident never happened I
didn't know anything about it nobody
told me anything about it and there was
a way for him to get up there and talk
about that incident and and insulate
himself he clearly didn't do that and
that's why he's in a jackpot now what if
he's telling the truth
well he's doing he's telling the truth
he's gonna still be the coach and I
think they love for him to still be the
coach but for him to be telling the
truth but he'll believe that the text
messages go ahead but Bruce how how do
you prove that somebody did or didn't
know something and you know how does he
how was he you know going to prove that
hey I didn't know I didn't know what was
going on here
you know maybe his wife knew but did she
tell him well that's exactly what's
gonna have to happen for him to
plausibly portray himself as being
unaware of this he's gonna have to say
yeah my wife knew about it because there
are text messages that would certainly
suggest that she did know but she never
told me and yeah my director of football
operations guys wife knew
he's by the way been with me at Bowling
Green Utah Gainesville and Columbus but
she didn't think it was important enough
to tell her husband whose job is to take
all the busy work off my plate that's
what you know I think it's a hard case
to make that a football coach who is you
know Dan every football coach every
great one is a control freak would be as
out of the loop on something like this
as Urban Meyer will have to be able to
convince people he was if he wants to
stick to his story yet he didn't know
anything about it
final five seconds is Urban Meyer the
coach of this team
opening game no he will not be the coach
of the team opening game beyond that I
don't know thank you Bruce we appreciate
your time he's a Bruce Huli morning host
of 105.7 whose only Fox affiliate in
Columbus Ohio for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]